fox businesses jerry baker wrote a
fantastic column in the wall street
journal this week where he pointed out
that critical race theory is inherently
illiberal because it rejects the very
principles of open inquiry at the heart
of western civilization and progress in
favor of the kind of
ideological indoctrination seen in
medieval europe or chairman mao's
cultural revolution in china
that's why it was so devastating and
depressing
to see the man in charge of our military
mark milley
pandering to wochism in congress last
week he said it's his job to understand
what's going on in america to teach all
points of view
but the entire purpose of wokism and
critical theory as we've explained here
many times
is to deny the validity of different
points of view
teaching it even tolerating it for one
second is the opposite
of what milli pompously claimed he's
doing at best
general milly's remarks were a sign of
intellectual laziness
at worst he was being completely
disingenuous either way
as the wall street journal editorial
board pointed out by so
recklessly taking a side in our most
contested cultural battle
milly has already put respect for the
military at risk
general milley has made himself a
divisive factional figure
and for that reason alone should be
removed immediately
jason chaffetz is back with us along
with political commentator and founder
of speak
georgia janelle king janelle great to
see you again um
janelle what are you i mean this this
whole episode i think is really
depressing
i mean you know one of the questions
that he was responding to there was
was the fact that he's giving out you
know books like how to be an anti-racist
by ibrahim you know it's
really bad stuff being given out
to our military what do you make of it
all yeah absolutely well this is clearly
a solution looking for a problem because
we live in a country
where we have a very very diverse
military matter of fact name one country
whose military
is more diverse in america and i would
venture to say that when our men and
women are standing side by side
each other looking at our adversaries in
the face i'm pretty sure no one cares
what your ethnicity is who is standing
beside you and who's going to be
fighting with you
at the end of the day i think we have to
make sure that we focus on the main
thing and the main thing
is that we are a diverse country and
when you put these type of
divisiveness and just you know
outlandish
things out here and when you're actually
telling our military people that there's
things that matter more than protecting
the country
you're absolutely forgetting why you're
there and what the whole focus is
um as to be to protect which is to
protect our country
and jason what's again they're
depressing is the word for this which is
you see
one after another time after time these
leaders whether in this case the
military you see
corporate leads and so on they just feel
they have to they just have to genuflect
at the altar of wokism
yeah janelle is absolutely right i mean
what you saw there
and and i like what you said steve he
was ultimately in pandering
unfortunately
some of these generals that get to this
stage the reason they're in these roles
is largely they've just become
politicians and they forget that their
number one goal and role
is to protect the united states they
make sure we got the biggest baddest
military on the face of the planet
they're to train warriors that can go
out and kill and defend
to provide logistics and move people and
armies
in places that where most people don't
want to go it's not to teach
everybody about how to be so politically
correct
that we lose sight of the ultimate goal
which is the defense of the united
states of america
and general milley based on those
comments that we heard has lost that
vision and lost the confidence of
millions of people
and and janelle it's it's you see it
right through
this our society now this the this march
of
workism but it's typically the
the real you know the the people really
pushing it they use this term allies the
white liberal
allies of of black people who are sort
of actually they're the ones
who's all constantly going on about all
this
yeah it's this really weird savior
mentality is as though
because of the color of my skin i'm
somehow less than i need to be saved by
someone who's not the same color as me
but the thing about is when you look at
critical race theory you know a seed
never looks like the fruit that it
produces and so you have to look at it
from a very overarching perspective and
what is the root what is the seed of
critical race theory and it's just
critical theory
you know we have people removing the
pledge from city council meetings
we have people removing god and we trust
from license plates which is an attack
on religious freedoms
attack on masculinity i mean when the
list goes on and on and on and that is
the seed
that is producing this fruit so we have
to move past
just critical race theory because that
is bad within itself but we're seeing a
whole attack happening
on everything religious freedoms and all
across the world so
i think we have to look much deeper into
what's happening here
and just very quickly jason your
reaction to an another example of what
janelle's talking about we just saw an
athlete
um kind of complaining about the
american athlete representing our
country complaining about the fact that
the american anthem was playing and the
flag was there
if you can't salute the flag of the
united states of america
then have the guts to not represent the
united states of america
go go play in some parks somewhere but
don't represent the united states the
red white and blue the stars and stripes
of the united states and try to go out
on the world stage by using your talent
when you won't even recognize and stand
for the flag that
it is so offensive to the men and women
who have given their life
to protect this country get rid of those
people participate in some other games
but not represent the united states
i'm glad i asked you that jason that was
very powerful really appreciate it thank
you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else